figurez bonjour Il est 16h05 et on va
vous parler aujourd'hui de Mars la
planète rouge puisque une belle
découverte a été faite ces derniers
temps et on va en parler pour en parler
chez Alex Vincent van danana bonjour
Vincent bonjour Vincent joyeuse science
au Figaro tout au long de ce live les
vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à poser vos
questions mais c'est d'y répondre on va
parler de ce qui se passe et de cet
article que vous venez que vous avez
écrit que vous me retrouver dans le
journal des météorites nous ouvrent le
cœur de mars des météorites nous ouvre
le corners expliquez-nous un peu de quoi
on parle
on parle en fait de sismologie il y a en
fait dans ce cette découverte dans cette
publication parce qu'il s'agit de deux
papiers publiés dans la rue science du
jour il y a plusieurs choses
extraordinaires et même c'est assez rare
de voir autant de
autant d'éléments importants réunis en
une seule découverte déjà on parle de
deux météorites dont on assistant direct
quasiment au crash sur la planète sur la
planète Mars ensuite on parle des
cratères d'impact qui sont les plus gros
jamais observés dans le système solaire
depuis sur les deux derniers siècles et
enfin on parle de d'enseignement sur le
cœur de mars donc c'est de c'est le
titre du du papier c'est à dire que
quand une météorite tombe tombe sur sur
la planète Mars elle va provoquer des
secousses et de ses secousses on va
réussir à comprendre un certain nombre
de choses sur
la structure de la planète alors on va
commencer par le début c'est un pacte
donc il y a des météorites qui sont
tombées sur Mars fin 2021 oui c'est ça
il y a deux météorites qui sont tombées
en septembre le 18 septembre 2021 et
l'autre un cadeau Noël le 24 décembre
alors des météorites qui tombent sur
Mars et c'est pas quelque chose
d'extraordinaire je rappelle que
l'atmosphère de la planète Mars est
extrêmement tenu donc
les météorites sont pas freinées
contrairement à ce qu'il peut y arriver
ce qui peut arriver sur terre ou pour le
coup il y a très peu d'un très peu de
d'impact d'impact récent mars
régulièrement bombarder mesquiers
fascinant dans cette découverte c'est
c'est la taille donc de ces cratères qui
dépassent les 130 mètres que je disais
tout à l'heure il s'agit tout simplement
des plus gros cratères d'impact du
système solaire sur les sur les deux
derniers siècles ce qui est une
découverte fabuleuse et ce qui est
incroyable c'est d'avoir cette
concomitance à deux mois d'écart de ces
éléments qui n'ont rien à voir une
probabilité d'avoir des des cratères
aussi gros qui est de l'ordre d'une fois
tous les tous les 10 ans on a deux en
deux mois quand j'ai eu les
scientifiques qui ont travaillé là
dessus nous ce que ça fait quand même
quelques temps que Mars et observé par
par les yeux et par les oreilles
humaines on reviendra tout à l'heure
quand on parlera des du de la sismologie
alors il s'attendent à avoir des des
impacts et ils s'attendaient ils
espèrent avoir un impact de d'une
trentaine de mètres mais avoir quelque
chose qui dépasse les 130 mètres et qui
attendait 150 m comme c'est le cas pour
le deuxième d'entre eux c'est vraiment
vraiment extraordinaire c'est c'est un
coup de chance finalement tout ça arrive
à ce moment-là on envoie
on envoie des robots pour ça aussi mais
là que ça règle les deux fois une fois
qu'on venait d'avoir des instruments de
mesure c'est quand même oui non c'est
c'est bien sûr que c'est c'est un coup
de chance et à la fois
ça devait arriver mais ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est la taille alors là
où c'est c'est un coup de chance c'est
ça c'est je lui dis pas forcément dans
papier parce que on est contraint pour
des questions de place et que bon
l'outil qui a permis de repérer ces
météorites je vais faire dans l'ordre on
a d'abord EPS mes théories grâce aux
orbiteurs qui tournent autour de la
planète ça veut dire c'est des petites
c'est des sondes qui caméra
qui est équipée de plusieurs caméras de
d'autres précisions qui a repéré qui a
repéré le cratère je reviendrai
peut-être tout à l'heure pour expliquer
un peu la chronologie précise ensuite on
a mesuré à l'aide du du sismographe donc
qui a un outil français c'est important
de dire qui équipe la sonde Insight qui
est sur la planète rouge depuis février
2019 si j'ai pas de bêtises plus en
papier mais des fois on se trompe sur
les dates comme ça
qui donc après a étudié les conséquences
de l'impact en terme de en termes de
Sismo de sismologie et donc à repérer
les différentes ondes etc là où il peut
y avoir un coup de chance c'est que
Insight c'est un c'est donc c'est c'est
un vaisseau qui est posé sur la sur la
planète rouge et qui est équipé de de
panneaux lumineux voltaïque qui lui
permet de fonctionner et il arrive parce
qu'il y a quand même quelques tempêtes
de sable sur Mars que ces panneaux
soient obstrués et qui ne puisse pas
fonctionner et donc il y a des périodes
de trous et qui plus est sur Mars il y a
beaucoup de bruit du bruit c'est pas je
parle pas du bruit ambi mais je parle de
la pollution quand on analyse des
données et des fois le vent ou ou le
sable peut amener quelques quelques
billets peut faire en sorte à ce que
Insight et en tout cas c'est ce qui est
le sismographe français ne fonctionne
pas correctement là les deux cratères
d'impact ont eu lieu au moment où
Insight et son sitemographe fonctionnait
bien ce qui est une bonne chose parce
que ça nous permet d'avoir ça et ce que
me disait un des scientifiques que j'ai
eu hier c'est que ça faisait trois
semaines jusqu'à hier qu'on avait plus
de nouvelles Insight ils ont renoué le
contact hier donc on a quand même eu de
la chance si on se réfère à ces petits
problèmes de de d'absence que qui sont
qui sont dues à la façon dont est fait
dans tes fait la sonde ça donc la son
inside c'est ça que vous voyez en haut à
gauche donc c'est une sonde de la NASA
qui est équipée donc d'un appareil
français de haute précision qui permet
de mesurer de de paper le pouls pour
avoir toutes les métaphores qu'on veut
au terme de en terme cardiaque mais
c'est exactement ça ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on colle l'oreille sur la planète et
on essaie de de voir quels sont ces ces
soubresauts c'est ce coup c'est spasme
essayer de comprendre comment il
fonctionne oui en plus ça c'est c'est
créateur d'impact qui soit assez loin de
cette tour on peut le voir 3100 km 7500
km
ça c'est c'est assez long ça va être
compliqué de s'y rendre oui alors ça va
être compliqué de s'y rendre il se
trouve que sur Mars il y a moins inside
façon un peu bouger mais il y a il y a
plusieurs Rover il y a trois Rover
curiosité persévérance qui sont des
Rover américain qui font partie d'une
mission assez large qui le but de voir
si sur la planète Mars on a un moment
donné les
conséquences des on a eu des conditions
excusez-moi réunies pour pour que la vie
puisse s'y développer et c'est
d'ailleurs une mission qui va renvoyer
des échantillons sur Terre on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler mais qui est
quand même extraordinaire il y a un
Rover chinois aussi et donc si si je me
souviens bien qui qui est sur la planète
mais ils sont très loin et ils sont
situés dans le même hémisphère mais à
des milliers de kilomètres et le temps
pour eux de s'y rendre enfin ils ont pas
suffisamment de batterie d'autonomie
quoi que ce soit même s'il y arrivait il
y aurait il y aurait plus grand chose à
appuyer sur place donc on ira pas à les
voir donc ce qui fait qu'on on pourra
pas trop savoir quels étaient ses corps
on a plusieurs interrogations qui
étaient à composition chimique en termes
de métaux lourds etc on pourra jamais
savoir ça mais
les écrase sur une planète ça crée des
turbulences des ondes qui vont se
répartir dans dans la surface de la
planète c'est le cas aussi sur Terre on
connaît mais tueur qui a quand même
causé les plus grandes catastrophes de
l'histoire de la planète avec la fin des
des dinosaures il y a 65 millions
d'années
là
on n'est pas sur des médiateurs qui font
la même taille ou quoi que ce soit on a
un tremblement de mars entre le moment
de mars d'une hauteur de 4 sur l'échelle
de Richter qui en compte 8 je dis pas de
bêtises ce qui est un événement très
important pour la planète Mars parce que
la l'activité géologique est plus faible
que que chez que chez nous le fait
d'avoir ce tremblement les ondes vont se
répartir sur les différentes couches de
la planète le manteau manteau inférieur
manteau supérieur et le temps qu'elles
arrivent à insight on va pouvoir
analyser les directions qu'elles ont
pris il y a plusieurs types d'ondes et
en fonction du type d'onde et des
directions du temps qu'elles ont mis
pour arriver on va pouvoir enfin moi je
le ferai pas mais les scientifiques vont
pouvoir calculer
les densité du manteau les différentes
couches comment est fait le noyau etc ce
qui est fascinant avec cette histoire
c'est que il y a déjà eu des séismes sur
Mars le séisme au record a été
enregistré en mai dernier il était de
4.7 donc un peu plus élevé que les deux
provoqués par
ces corps par ses corps célestes mais là
on connaît précisément le lieu d'origine
et c'est ça qui est important c'est que
il y a une largeur sur les calculs qui
est quasiment nul parce que on sait d'où
par l'impact et on sait où il arrive
donc ce qui permet de revoir tous les
modèles voilà on va pouvoir calculer
alors si je vulgariser un peu c'est à
dire qu'on va connaître quel est le type
de de sol on va dire traverser par les
ondes selon la façon selon la vitesse à
laquelle ça se diffuse parce que grosso
modo
que sur la terre donc du coup ce sera en
fonction de la densité
un peu difficile à Paris et surtout il y
a des des lignes de rupture des
discontinuités entre les différents
manteaux c'est pareil sur Terre une
différence de densité même de
composition chimiques alors la
composition chimique on pourra pas
l'avoir tout de suite mais en tout cas
sur la densité on a des idées sur l'état
aussi et ces lignes discontinuité vont
modifier la trajectoire des gens qui est
assez logique en fait ça se visualise
très bien il faut imaginer des cercles
concentriques et quand une onde arrive
au niveau d'un cercle et va être un peu
modifié c'est un trajectoire va être un
peu modifié et donc c'est trajectoires
vont influer sur le sur le temps de le
temps de parcours et sur aussi leur
forme et donc c'est comme ça qu'on
arrive à comprendre donc le supérieur
manteau inférieur noyau et là ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les ondes en
surface on parcouru de manière assez
prévisible le manteau donc ce qu'on
savait ce qu'on croyait savoir en tout
cas sur le sur la partie supérieure de
de l'intérieur de mars c'était
relativement juste en revanche
il y a des anomalies parce qu'on appelle
les anomalies parce que c'est parce
qu'on prévoyait avec la partie la partie
inférieure donc il semblerait qu'il y
ait une couche entre le manteau
inférieur et le noyau dont on n'avait
pas connaissance en tout cas dans les
précédents séismes n'avaient pas pu nous
renseigner il faut rappeler que les
précédent séisme déjà on ne connaissait
pas leur lieu d'origine ce qui fait que
il y a des problèmes sur les ce que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure il marche
d'erreur très importante et ensuite
quand il s'agissait de cratère d'impact
c'était beaucoup plus proche de la sonde
donc eux ils rentraient moins en
profondeur ce qui explique pourquoi
est-ce que il y a cette inconnue et
c'est là-dessus qui a quand même une
excitation dans la communauté
scientifique c'est qu'on va pouvoir
grâce à ces deux impacts mieux connaître
l'intérieur de mars ce qui est un enjeu
important parce que le but c'est de
comprendre comment est-ce que cette
planète est une jumelle de la soeur qui
aurait de la terre pardon qui ne sera
jamais de la terre qui aurait pu
accueillir la ville et devenu un enfer
invivable total et peut-être qu'une
partie de cette réponse est dans sa
géologie ça parce que sa géologie de
base je pensais que c'était elle était
assez proche de celle de la Terre en
fait elle est composé de manteau de
d'une croûte d'un noyau donc c'est vrai
que c'est c'est des plaines qui se
ressemblent beaucoup et le but c'est
d'essayer de comprendre qu'est-ce qui a
fait qui a une différence comme ça entre
entre les deux quoi là il y avait une
des premiers résultats publier d'une
site il y a un peu inside donc je répète
à son américain publié un peu plus d'un
an qui déjà nous montrer donc ces
différents strates et nous laisser
entendre que l'incertitude n'était pas
absolue là-dessus mais que devrait y
avoir un noyau à à peu près liquide donc
un peu comme comme sur la terre il y a
des points d'interrogation sur
à l'intérieur de ce noyau une bille une
bille beaucoup plus dense et plus dure
donc ça c'est des réponses qu'on espère
avoir avec des événements
similaires à ces impacts et à des
séismes très forts je me souviens la
première fois que j'ai eu des
scientifiques pour me parler d'Inside
donc il y a en 2019 bon des premiers
résultats ils étaient bon un peu déçus
parce qu'il n'avait pas eu de séisme
supérieur à deux sur l'échelle sur
l'échelle de Richter et donc ils avaient
des premiers résultats mais ils
attendaient quand même un gros événement
et là on peut tant il y a eu cinq
séismes à plus de à plus de 4 dont ces
deux cratères et dont l'événement de mai
dernier qui est pas encore publié donc
ça on attend avec impatience pour ceux
que ça intéresse la publication des
résultats dans une dans une revue et il
est fort à parier que que on est là
encore de de nouveaux enseignements sur
sur la structure de cette planète sera à
ce moment-là alors vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure quelque chose d'assez
important c'est que
Mars touchée par des météorites parce
qu'il y a pas elle a pas de filet de
protection comme ça comme la terre c'est
ça exactement il a une émotion est très
tenue
très très faible et donc les les corps
et les corps étrangers les météores
quand ils rentrent dans l'atmosphère
martienne sont sont beaucoup moins
freinés sur terre ils vont totalement se
disloquer le le dernier gros événement
comparable il est du début du siècle en
Russie et je vais pas me risquer à dire
le le mot de la ville en Sibérie parce
que il m'échappe et j'aurais peur de de
l'écorcher
et qui avait créé d'énormes dégâts les
vitres elles avaient explosé et pourtant
malgré ça rien n'avait touché la terre
c'est-à-dire que tout c'était c'était
totalement explosé et dissout en hauteur
attitude mais c'était c'était une très
grosse une très grosse météorite c'était
Chelia bean
alors moi je triche parce que j'ai
l'ordinateur donc voilà c'est aussi plus
facile on a mis une question sur les
images qu'on voit actuellement donc il y
a des images qui sont des photos et des
images qui sont des reconstances des des
des constitutions d'artistes alors là ce
qui est publié c'est les photos de MRO
là ce qui est ce qui est bien je sais
pas si long à l'écran
mais on voit très bien entre le 24
décembre et le 25 décembre le cratère
donc il y a enfin mars on a des images
incroyables vraiment on ne se lasse pas
de de ce qui nous est renvoyé ça c'est
une photo ça c'est une photo ça c'est
une photo pris par un satellite je sais
pas lequel il sait pas censé sur le
effectivement mais mais oui oui on a
alors l'avantage en fait ce qui s'est
passé pour raconter la genèse de de
cette découverte au mois de septembre il
y a une activité assez forte autour de
autour de Insight en terme d'impact
en parallèle
en Bretagne dans au dessus des
scientifiques qui bossent sur inside qui
sont répartis un peu partout dans le
monde il y a quand même pas mal de
français je disais parce que le
cœur de de l'outil et français voit donc
de visu dans le ciel c'est des météores
etc donc il y a une discussion autour de
de ces impacts et Insight enregistre
donc
[Musique]
une activité sismique différente de ce
qu'elle a l'habitude d'enregistrer c'est
à dire que d'habitude un enregistre que
les ondes qui sont à l'intérieur et là
elle va enregistrer aussi tes ondes de
surface les ondes de surface ça peut
être un très gros tremblement à
proximité ou un tremblement de terre qui
est très proche de la surface parce que
je rappelle que les tremblement de terre
ils sont pas forcément le point
d'origine n'est pas forcément tout en
haut il peut être peut être la
différence niveau au niveau de la croûte
et
en fait ils avaient ces résultats ils
pouvaient pas il pouvait pas avoir de
certitudes d'où ça venait en parallèle
donc il y a une une sonde martienne
Amero qui qui tournait et qui est passé
au dessus au dessus de de ce premier
impact et le qui est le s10001 et qui a
pris la photo et au moment où la photo a
commencé à circuler dans le autour de
dans le milieu dans le milieu martien
tout de suite les scientifiques inside
on fait le rapprochement entre cette
activité particulière qui aurait pu être
un impact dont tu n'avais pas de preuve
cette actualité autour des impacts et
cette photo est donc là ils ont envoyé
il y a des Bridge qui tourne autour
qu'on peut piloter etc donc ils ont
envoyé des satellites pour pour vérifier
au dessus de la zone et ils étaient en
alerte quoi ce qui fait que deux mois
après quand quand un deuxième satellite
comme un deuxième corps céleste est
tombé sur sur la planète ils ont tout de
suite pu avoir les images rapidement et
il s'est rendu compte que là ils avaient
à nouveau un très gros impact et même le
pour le coup le plus gros cratère mais
c'est celui qui mesure 150m alors on l'a
dit il y a trois Rover sur Mars est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir envoyer l'un d'eux
aller voir ce qui se passe c'est une
question que j'ai posé mais
malheureusement on pourra pas ils sont
beaucoup trop loin donc ils ont pas les
bons déjà une mission martienne c'est
extrêmement important l'émission de
curiosity persévérance et donc elles
sont essentielles voilà le but c'est
quand même trouver des traces de des
conditions nécessaires pour la vie donc
dans une zone vraiment importante à un
delta du G0 qui est qui a un autre
cratère mais qui lui est un cratère
naturel lié à la dans un ancien lac il
est arrivé dans le delta il y a quelques
semaines donc là où il pourrait y avoir
des minéraux très favorables à une vie
microscopique donc il est vraiment sur
une zone de tension très forte et on va
pas le l'enlever de cette mission pour
pour aller voir ses cratères d'impact
c'est à la fois dommage et à la fois on
exprime même aussi que les résultats
persévérance soit soit fascinant donc
il faut voir le temps que ce qui est
dommage c'est parce que sur le cratère
de décembre
des scientifiques on remarqué que il y
avait eu de la glace qui avait été
excavée du du de l'impact donc c'est à
dire qu'il y a des blocs de glace
autour autour du cratère et tout
simplement qu'il y avait de la glace sur
place et on s'attendait pas à trouver de
la glace à cet endroit là donc
pourquoi il y a la glace quel type de
glace c'est bon c'est pas de la glace
d'eau bien bien entendu il fait j'ai
trop froid c'est de la glace azote
d'où il vient etc donc ça c'est des
questions malheureusement tu n'auras pas
la réponse parce que le quand bien même
on enverrai un Rover le temps que qu'il
arrive la glace sera totalement sublimée
donc c'est qu'il sera passé directement
l'état solide à l'état gazeux donc on
pourra pas on pourra pas l'analyser
voilà alors parce qu'il y a pas mal de
questions quand même sur ça souvent
c'est que là c'est mars qui est touché
mais si et nous nous ça veut dire que si
des météorites touchent mars c'est pas
très loin de chez nous elle pourrait
aussi très bien nous toucher alors les
deux météorites qui ont touché Marthe
sont vus de leur de leur taille j'ai pas
la taille en mètre parce que si c'est
surtout le poids qui compte qui 250 à
650 tonnes si je me trompe pas
elle aurait pas fait grand chose sur
terrestre et totalement sur les les
étoiles filantes et donc il y a pas
grand chose à craindre alors ce qui est
inquiétant pour la terre c'est des c'est
des météorites beaucoup plus grosses et
donc de type de type péninsule du Qatar
et des dinosaures bien entendu parce que
pour le coup on dit ça rigole mais c'est
vrai que c'est déjà arrivé que ça me
faisait des des dégâts irrémédiable donc
il y a des il y a des projets
scientifiques là dessus on envoie une
fléchette sur la story il y a pas si
longtemps exactement le projet d'art de
la NASA et donc ce qui était positif
parce qu'on a réussi à à dévier de sa
course il s'agit pas d'exploser les
astéroïdes on va pas y aller pour pour
faire exploser je pense que déjà c'est
beaucoup trop dangereux mais le but
c'est de dévier et le le test qui a été
fait donc sur Darty a bien fonctionné le
le satellite a bien bien changé sa
trajectoire après après avoir été touché
par par la fléchette humaine très bien
bah écoutez merci beaucoup Vincent en
tout cas merci à vous d'avoir été
nombreux je rappelle votre papier que
vous pouvez retrouver sur le site du
Figaro des météorites nous ouvrent le
cœur de mars très intéressant et vous
pouvez tout retrouver sur le site du
Figaro et beaucoup d'articles
intéressants dans la rubrique science et
bien sûr sur toutes les rubriques du
Figaro bien évidemment la suite du
programme c'est à 17h30 avec la question
du jour je recevrai Guillaume Erard et
18h c'est point de vue présenté par
timothélem à bientôt pour de nouveaux
live sur Fiori